and women's standards have gotten so
high guys that gay men are taking notice
men that are not interested in women at
all they they don't want to deal with
women they're gay they notice that
women's standards are crazy high let's
pull it up the average woman in Miami
walks around looking like an absolute
hooker like I'm talking like an actual
prostitute I'm talking about like actual
only fans like they literally walk
around like I was walking around in
Brickle early here and they're walking
around in these little outfits like
their bbl's are hanging out like their
ass is hanging out you know their boobs
are hanging out and they think it's cute
because they all look like it but they
don't know how crazy they all look and
like you're never going to bag like a
man of mem looking like that because
he's just going to run through you and
run on to the next